[Music]  we've teamed up with Spotify to find out  which music fans have been especially  nice this year Spotify is making a list  and checking it twice to find music  superfans they're collaborating with  some of the year's biggest acts  including SIA dnce and Fetty WAP is  wrapping paper for rappers who Rattrap  like me goals young dog and me very well  wrap them with trapping papers easy to  thank some of their most loyal fans  Spotify will surprise them with these  custom-designed gifts like acción de hat  a fruit cake by the ocean and corn iment  treat you better sweater from shawn  mendes taking the ugly Christmas sweater  thing to a whole new level plus a  personalized message from the artists  themselves  check out Spotify Instagram and follow  hashtag 2016 brands hope you made the  list happy holidays  [Music]  you